doing less than doing more at the same  time making fewer changes and doing more  repeating successful actions like okay  well if we're spending this much spend  more if we have three sales guys get  sick just expanding instead of changing  yeah and i think one of the mistakes  that a lot of earlier entrepreneurs  myself included make is that we want to  put jetpacks on a two-seater and figure  out how to get more out of this thing  rather than just admitting the fact that  you just need a bigger [ __ ] car yeah  right and that's it like you still need  to drive the same way you just need a  bigger car  and so it just means sometimes you just  have to get more sales guys you just  have to spend more money you don't need  to change your business model to make  more money you just need to do more of  what you're already doing